the long wait for Netflix's liveaction
adaptation of avatar The Last air bender
is nearly over and a lot of information
has come out since the series was first
announced here's everything you need to
know about the series in one place
Netflix's avatar The Last Airbender will
debut on February 22nd 2024 and fans
have been waiting for that date for
quite some time many years have passed
since the project was first announced in
2018 and some of them offered virtually
nothing in the way of production updates
for a long time the entire series seemed
more like a far off dream than an actual
production fans might get to lay eyes on
someday now that those many months of
waiting are behind us the teaser trailer
and promotional images we've seen seem
like all that wait time may have been
Justified Netflix's take on avatar The
Last Airbender looks to be a beautifully
realized adaptation of the original
story full of gorgeous costumes
elaborate environments and complex
visual effects if it took a while to get
them all just right well so be it I'm
done dwelling on the past like the
original cartoon Netflix's avatar the
Last a bender takes place in a
Fantastical World dominated by four
great Nations the sprawling Earth
Kingdom the peaceful air Nomads the
tight-knit water tribe and the
imperialistic Fire Nation certain people
in every region are capable of
manipulating their nation's element
through a wide variety of martial arts
known as bending the Avatar who is the
only person capable of bending all four
elements connects these nation's
Material World to the spirit world and
keeps both in Balance the world is
suffering a serious lack of balance when
the Story begins as the Avatar a
12-year-old air Nomad named an has been
missing for 100 years everything changes
when water tribe siblings qara and
sucker stumble upon him and his Flying
Bison APPA Frozen in stasis in an
enormous Iceberg Ang must now contend
with a world ravaged by the Fire Nation
Century long campaign of Conquest
notably the Netflix series will not be a
one- forone adaptation of the cartoon as
showrunner Albert Kim explained to
Entertainment Weekly we don't start the
show the way the Animated Series starts
that was a conscious decision to show
people this is not the Animated Series
we had to sometimes unravel story lines
and remix them in a new way to make
sense for a serialized drama as the
intense criticism for its liveaction
predecessor ight shyamalan's Infamous
the last air bender will show a good
cast is critical to the success of
Netflix's avatar The Last Airbender
Shyamalan made the mistake of casting
multiple white actors for characters of
color and original series creators
Michael Dante deino and Brian kitko made
it clear from the beginning that
Netflix's take would not be repeating
this mistake the lead Trio of good guys
will consists of Gordon Cormier as Ang
gu Ando as qara and Ian sley as soccer
me myself I'm a pretty big fan of the
show so even I'm really excited for that
while all three actors are at the
beginning of their careers fans might
know Guan Dio as quet from am with an e
and the titular heroine of beans Dallas
Lou Elizabeth U Paul son hung Lee and
Daniel Day Kim will bring the Fire
Nation to life at Zuko aula iro and oai
respectively S Young Lee's presence is a
good sign as he's Charmed millions of
fans as Mr Kim on Kim's Convenience and
as Carson Taver on the Mandalorian
Daniel Day Kim who starred in Hellboy
Riot and the last dragon and Hawaii 5 is
another jewel in the series Crown
notably this won't be his first trip to
the Avatar universe as he voiced General
Fang in the original animated series and
to roshi Sato in avatar The Legend of
Kora The Supporting Cast is also full of
luminaries Community star Danny py will
portray the Kookie mechanist whose
inventions are as brilliant as they are
dangerous Star Trek Legend George te
will play The Fearsome Spirit Co who
steals the faces of those unlucky lucky
enough to cross his path Amber Med
Thunder who blew audiences away with her
star turn as Naru in prey will portray
the Soulful princess UA inmation this is
a seriously stucked cast and fans
couldn't be happier well fans are
naturally eager to see what the
liveaction versions of the original
avatar The Last Airbender characters
will be like not all major characters in
the new show Will hail directly from the
Animated
[Music]
Series
my garbages there will be at least one
brand new character in Netflix's Avatar
named ukari who is played by Tomlin to
according to deadline yukari is the
mother tsuki a friend of the protagonist
from the cartoon yukari will also be the
mayor of the small community on Koshi
Island filling a small but significant
narrative Gap in the original Kyoshi
Island plotline the villagers political
and social organization are very vaguely
defined in the original show there is a
leader ERS ship figure in the show's
depiction of the island but his role is
very small the episode came early on in
the animated series before the writers
more adventurous foray into detailed
political narratives yukari's presence
suggests that the Kyoshi Island plot may
be expanded and deepened Beyond the more
casual adventure of the week role it
initially fulfilled to meet her is best
known for her roles in the Karate Kid
Part Two And The Joy Luck Club though
she has over a 100 credits on her
impressive resume Albert Kim will serve
a show owner executive producer and
writer on Netflix's avatar The Last
Airbender however this wasn't always the
case when the show was first announced
in September 2018 original series
creators Michael Dante de Martino and
Brian kitko were named as the
adaptations executive producers and
showrunners sadly in August 2020 de
Martino announced the duo had Departed
the project in a post on his website in
August 2021 Albert Kim emerged as the
Project's new showrunner in a post to
the the Netflix website Kim oine that
his daughter got him hooked on the show
and that he's particularly excited by
the possibilities inherent in modern
visual effects and the Netflix model
while the potential excites him he also
noted that following kitko and de
Martino came with some pressure he
explained to Entertainment Weekly you'd
have to be an idiot not to be
intimidated a little bit my first
reaction after hell yeah was holy do I
really want to do this to prove your
worth as Scholars you have to contribute
some worthwhile
knowledge luckily he did get a little
time to sit down with the original Duo
and talk about the story before they
departed while Kim is undoubtedly
working hard to make the best show he
can there are still many who are
skeptical about the series since the
Martino and kenito parted ways with the
project in his open letter to fans D
Martino revealed the reason he left was
due to the fact that he quote couldn't
control the creative direction of the
series he wrote Netflix's live action
adaptation of Avatar has the potential
to be good it might turn out to be a
show many of you end up enjoying but
what I can be certain about is that
whatever version ends up on screen it
will not be what Brian and I had
envisioned or intended to make despite
their departure Di matino and kitko
still have writing credits on two
episodes the series premiere was written
by them and showrunner Albert Kim and
the sixth episode has a story by the
creators and Uber Muhammad best known
for her work on Legends of Tomorrow
additionally the Telly play for the
sixth episode is credited to kitko
alongside Marvel Comics writer Emily Kim
and Netflix writer's assistant Hunter re
Netflix's avatar the Last air bender
will be directed by Michael rosan
leang Jabar Rani and Jet Wilkinson this
is an impressive bunch of people with
experience in nearly every genre has
directed episodes of Empire chilling
Adventures of Sabrina Big Sky and
Riverdale Wilkinson is similarly
prolific having helmed installments of
the shy Warrior Daredevil and how to get
away with murder Rani has served in
various capacities on a number of
celebrated shows including Game of
Thrones and the Flash finally Le Yang's
directorial resume consists of generally
lower profile work that is nonetheless
impressive including crey Friday night
bites and Shadow in the cloud with the
exception of Wilkinson all of these
directors will also serve as producers
on avatar the Last air bender they'll be
joined by Kurt Williams Bonnie R benwick
Mark David Alper Ryan helprin Dan Lynn
and Lindsay Liberator taken together
this group boasts a truly massive
filmography studed with excellent
projects like maid Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol The Lego Movie and Logan
Benjamin wi and Jeremy zuckerman's music
was one of the most essential elements
of the original avatar The Last
Airbender animated series back when
Netflix's liveaction adaptation was
still fresh news there was a point when
it actually seemed as though the
streamer's commitment to recapturing the
magic of Source material extended to
bringing back Zuckerman in fact the
composer even indicated in a 2018 tweet
that it'd be involved in the remake
however following de Martino and kisko's
departure Zuckerman confirmed on X
formerly known as Twitter that he would
no longer be providing the music for the
Netflix series the identity of the
composer for the liveaction Avatar The
Last air bender series wasn't confirmed
until February 2023 when Japanese
American Musician teshi Furukawa was
revealed to be taking over in a tweet
announcing the news through aawa wrote
it is a tremendous honor to announce my
involvement on Netflix's epic liveaction
remake of avatar The Last air bender and
truly humbled to receive stewardship of
the incredible themes from the original
series we are hard at work to elevate
this to new heights so stay tuned FAL C
is a prolific composer whose credits
extend from film and television to video
games the recipient of multiple Award
nominations for his work on the 2016
PlayStation 4 game The Last Guardian he
also provided the music for the 2008 CGI
animated film Star Wars the Clone Wars
as well as the Beloved Clone Wars series
so I hope you enjoy the music as much as
I did composing it as is often the case
with big Productions the visual effects
for avatar The Last Airbender will be
overseen by an array of different VFX
Studios working together among the cooks
in the kitchen will be the British
Studio D formerly known as double
negative one of the most sought after
VFX housers in the world today D has
worked on too many major films and TV
shows to list however some of their
recent notable credits include the last
of us the Lord of the Rings the rings of
power and stranger things according to
the Studio's official website they will
be supplying virtual Production Services
for Netflix's Avatar series IMDb also
currently lists two other visual effect
Studios among the series company credits
image engine design and pixomondo image
engine is a Canadian Studio that has
recently offered its services to TV
series including Ahsoka the Mandalorian
and moonnight as well as films like
birds of prey Pokémon detective Pikachu
Spider-Man far from home and Disney's
liveaction remake of Mulan pixomondo a
studio founded in Germany in 2001 and
currently headquartered in Los Angeles
has had a hand in many big shows and
films including House of the Dragon the
boys and Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
mania one of the reasons why avatar the
Last air bender was long being
considered such a difficult story to
adapt to another medium is the fact that
it's already so perfectly suited to the
running time of a three season 60
episode series when Netflix announced
that season 1 of its adaptation would
only be Eight Episodes long some fans
wondered if that would be enough to do
justice to all of book one water
interestingly enough despite the shorter
episode count the season will actually
be roughly equal to its animated
counterpart in terms of runtime since
all episodes will be an hour in length
what this means is that each episode of
Netflix's Avatar season 1 is likely to
contain stories from multiple 22-minute
installments from book one with the
season's general plot roughly
corresponding to the animated series The
live action shows writers have played
Koy about how faithful the first season
will be in terms of plot coverage but
Albert Kim has said that the longer
episode run times mean that they can
flesh out the most important parts of
the story this could mean that less
consequential episodes such as the Great
Divide and the fortune teller may be EXC
Additionally the presence of aula May
and Ty Lee is an interesting wrinkle
that points to some measure of
restructuring since they didn't properly
join the original series until book two
one of the reasons avatar the Last air
bender stood apart from other animated
shows of its time was its attention to
geography taking place on an ocean
planet much like Earth the series took
care to always set episodes and
storylines in specific parts of its
world the viewers could easily recognize
book one is particularly impressive in
the that regard because it convincingly
charts a round the world trip from the
south to the north with gradual climate
shifts to pull off that same level of
attention to detail the liveaction
series picked a filming location that
can stand in for several different areas
of the Avatar World British Colombia as
of January 2024 we know that the show
was shut largely in and around the
Vancouver area with a combination of
location shooting and Sound Stage work
it has been reported by Avatar news that
some of the filming was done in the How
Sound fi as for the South Pole and North
Pole scenes The Verge reports that the
show will be bringing them to life via a
massive virtual soundstage full of
gigantic LED panels in early 2021
Paramount Global then known as Viacom
CBS announced a new division at
Nickelodeon named Avatar Studios Avatar
Studios would be tasked with developing
new movies and shows set in the universe
of avatar The Last air bender and the
legend of Kora the news broke 3 years
after the announcement of the live Act
ction avatar the Last Air vender series
leading some to speculate about whether
the Netflix series will be part of the
upcoming Avatar Studios portfolio while
Avatar Studios does have a production
credit on the liveaction series this is
likely only due to D Martino and
konito's involvement in the development
stage Avatar Studios were set up by D
Martino and kitko after they left
Netflix's Avatar with the aim of
focusing on new animated projects set in
the same universe and continuity as the
last air bender and the legend of cor
now we're getting to expand the
franchise in different directions all at
once as a results the live action series
will likely have a completely separate
cannon from any of the shows films or
other content to come out of Avatar
Studios the elephant in the room when it
comes to Netflix's avatar the Last air
bender series is the fact that the
series already has one liveaction
adaptation and it was not received well
ight shyamalan's the last air bender
became legendary not only for for its
cinematic shuttin but for its complete
disregard of the key themes ideas
character arcs and worldbuilding details
of the source material it even got the
titular character's name
wrong an flew us to his home he told us
how he left there in a storm on AA the
fear of another Fiasco among fans is not
lost on the creators of Netflix's Avatar
showrunner Albert Kim noted that he had
never watched the shamalan film and made
a point of avoiding it once his work on
the series was underway he explained to
Entertainment Weekly there was a period
of time where I thought I should watch
it but then I thought I don't really
want those images in my head as I start
to go forward with our version of this
project so I avoided it purposefully he
clarified however that he was aware of
the most prevalent criticism against the
movie and worked to write those wrongs
with the series Additionally the fact
that season 1 will have a similar
overall run time to book one of the
Animated Series it's an encouraging
response to fans of voiced opinion that
the 201 10 film condenser shows story
past the point of comprehension despite
being animated shows both avatar the
Last air bender and the legend of Kora
features some very memorable fight
choreography to ensure that all four
Elemental bending techniques were
brought to life with as much complexity
as possible both shows employed martial
arts teams these teams were led by
martial arts expert and reference actor
tfu kisu who planned and acted out
choreography which was then recorded and
studied by the animators this resulted
in fight scenes that are on par with
many liveaction shows the combat aspect
of the Avatar universe is dear to fans
so the pressure is on to get it right in
the Netflix show the men in charge of
translating this to live action are
stunt coordinator Alex kishk ofic and
fight instructor Alan Tang kovich a
veteran stum performer who has been
working on major films and TV shows for
over a decade is best known for his work
in the superhero genre he served as
fight coordinator on HBO Max's
Peacemaker and previously worked on
X-Men Days of Future Past and Deadpool 2
Tang meanwhile has ample experience as a
stunt coordinator both in films and on
TV shows his notable credits include the
Dwayne Johnson Blockbuster skyscraper
Star Trek Discovery and the Umbrella
[Music]
Academy